the reason that I became involved in the
Citizens United case and I represented
Senator McConnell in that case and was
one of the four lawyers who argued in
that case the reason I became involved
in the case was because I thought it was
contrary to the First Amendment at its
deepest and most important level to
limit political speech there's nothing
more important nothing in the speech
world then speech about who to vote for
and yet the case revolved around a
documentary put out by a right-wing
group denouncing Hillary Clinton as a
candidate for president well the First
Amendment I know and I voted for Hillary
Clinton but the the First Amendment I
know would tell me that that's a bad as
high on the list a protected material as
anything could possibly be and so to be
told well because it's a corporation
they shouldn't get protection and they
can be basically have that speech
criminalized simply isn't the first
amendment that that I think we have and
it is not a good thing also from a
social policy point of view for the US
government to become involved in
deciding what the different
organizations created by people
associations of of individuals
corporations unions whatever I can say
or not say so for example and for me to
compare the Citizens United case to
another case decided just three months
later in which Congress had passed a law
basically saying that movies could not
be distributed showing that torture
maiming and killing of animals a market
had to be created for that and congress
passed a law saying well let that sort
of movie shouldn't be allowed the
supreme court all agreed that the speech
there was of absolutely no value at all
they used the word justice alito
dissenting but the majority didn't take
issue with it the speech had no value
and if anything did arm but the court
said look we live in a free country and
the First Amendment has decided for us
that even speech which we think really
is the bad stuff even valueless speech
this speech which is permitted I agreed
with that opinion but when I read
various or organizations newspapers and
alike saying now that's a good opinion
in defending the First Amendment but
that citizens united is a bad opinion
and I say to myself what's going on here
the the movies of dogs being tortured to
death serve no good purpose at at the
least they've they trash society's
lessons and indeed that they portray
conduct that is illegal in every state
in the country but there we say we will
protect that speech when it comes to
political speech engaged in by
corporations and unions will say they
can't do that well I don't understand
that I think that that is wrong wrong as
a constitutional matter wrong as a First
Amendment matter and wrong as a public
policy matter I mean if you made me
choose in the two cases throw out the
First Amendment
Social Policy alone I would say well I
mean of course I mean that showing
showing the murder and maiming of dogs
and cats is awful as a social policy
matter harmful in the sense that the
animals might not even be killed but for
the filming and sale of it harmful and
what it teaches our children harmful to
everything we believe about humanity so
if you made me say well you can only
have one I would say well at least
protect political speech if you must
throw bad speech over the side political
speech by definition isn't bad speech
it's what it's what we're all about and
so by my lights citizens united was a
correct decision and I find it
disturbing that so many people whose
views are often share but so many people
who think that they are supporters of
the First Amendment have denounced the
Citizens United opinion